bene a tutti ragazzi che sono io ma non
so parlamento sono fare i geni oggi
siamo su drunken bouar scazzottate al
bar in bar banchieri ma proviamo allora
ragazzi ho visto questo gioco sullo
store e non ho resistito perché volevo
prendere a calci la gente quindi mi
spiega come ci si muove
ci si muove solo all indietro ma se
vuole andare avanti non vadano avanti
muoviamoci come i gamberi praga o non so
non capisco come ci si muove in su gioca
un'ora
come posso solo girare la visuale ma non
posso muovermi non posso muovermi
buongiorno salve e sono entrato salve
devo fare ma ho le mani scusatemi arco
invertiti cosi buongiorno highlab this
music me lo è ora
ora è a rio del music gray frate e
divertiti maledizione che la vita è una
e domani te sei pregio viene giocare col
fa vi potremo fare qua a senti se non ti
diverti però alla stringimi la mano a
piacere piacere piace premi la mano la
mano
salve posso fare la sua conoscenza prima
regola del fight club mai parlare di fa
vj invano hai capito
ci sono dei problemi di comunicazione a
fratello le paste buongiorno a cosa mi
fa il dito medio
cosa che vuoi beh mannaia cos'è che vuoi
dolore il pat ricavate che cartelle box
è la madonna che mai
è il gioco più bello del mondo
buongiorno ragazzi domandiamo l'altro
giorno tutto un po da ridire con un
amico karl dei problemi allora lo so che
il mondo del lavoro
signor cravatta yo è difficile però io
le posso mica offrire una buonissima
birra vabbè ciò ke ci siamo lo shampoo
col don pero signore già che ci siamo io
le regalerei anche delle freccette che
ho trovato qui le vuole le freccette
senza che buone sono almeno è contento
ma no tu non lo fai così ha mai capito
se pavia è morto ce l'hai attaccata al
dito zio è madonna che cartelle ritiro
si dice con chi hai a che fare fratello
ma sim per cent senti io non ho le
braccia dritta e mi dai una mano però
non devi picchiarmi sono tenendo la
famiglia non ha cosa vuoi tu
sto male sto prendendo con lui cosa sei
goku ragazzi aiuto c'è lager mi
picchiano
ma per quale motivo perché non ho fatto
niente aiuto aiuto
non so cosa fare tieni era vittima
fratello non è che puoi fare quello che
vuoi d'altri tempi ma tirato un calcio
in bocca su pezzente allora dobbiamo
capirci zio senti se tu hai questo
sguardo da pirla lo capisci che non è
colpa mia se tifi con destro madonna lo
steso fortissimo duro dic avorare che
non ho fatto niente contro di te anzi ti
offre un caffè vieni zona vi era una
birra una birra la guerra birra da voi
robbie lavori
birra da voi sta birra qua da voi la
birra
attendo tutte quelle che vuoi ti do
becca di telemaco letta cosa vuoi tu
davvero steso prima anaya ragazzi quel
problema è molto più gravi di quanto
pensassi
cos'è ma sono io quello del gioco che è
molto più strano di quanto pensassi
prova demerita 13 euro per picchiare la
gente scusa domanda ma se io entro qui
cosa succeda c'è quello texano c'è la
scazzottata nel texas poi vede
addirittura ma va bè ragazzi questo
gioca veramente family friendly e lo sai
mai che non ci sono più gli amici di una
volta lo sorso ti ricordi quando
andavamo alle scuole ci sedevamo sul
banco e tiravamo le cartacce quelli
davanti
mamma mia come sono cambiati i tempi
mike ti ricordi anche la prima cotta non
sarà te la ricordi sarno io ci provavo
tutti i giorni
e lei nomi cagava allora ci ho chiesto
aiuto e si è andato da sara e lei detto
c'è un ragazzo che ti pensa si chiama
lorenzo
il giorno dopo è stato il giorno più
assurdo della mia vita
entra in classe e sarah stava limo nando
con te brutto pec sente lui tirò gli
aiuti gli aiuti ti chiedo ti chiedo di
aiuti e tu limoni con la mia ragazza
tutto schifoso cane sciacquati la bocca
quando parli come l'acqua ti la bocca
pure smettila di rimanare le mie ragazze
brutto schifoso parassita pezzente
inutile al mondo meretrice di tua
sorella morta la finiamo siamo amici
sono al momento del peso del bisogno
adesso mi rechi piedi bravo leccami
piedi per preferisci ragazzi e queste
storie mi prendono molto su personale
non è colpa mia io provo a fare
ma non funziona purtroppo non funziona
franklin guardiamo ai sempre sto codino
della mia ascolta fra ho sentito la
canzone no questo ciò che io non ho però
prende la chitarra york la posta no la
chitarra volo prima chitarra la chitarra
la chitarra volevo prendere l'ho presa e
tu a questa fender non è che mi presti
per caso una batteria robben dopo la
stowe vino rosso che chuck pro vasto che
non ho mancato senti ma cosa vuoi tu
indica ga ma più piccolo gap ittica
quante family friendly sto gioco ragazzi
incredibile la mangiati lo sgabello
bravo bravo ma non c'è solo l'aver si è
rotto porco schifo mi servirebbero un
estintore grazie
scusi ma lei non c'entra niente me sto
parlando con un amico stavo parlando con
gli all in guardia il casinò guarda che
cosa mi fa fare lei guardi la smetta
volevo parlare di chitarre e tu non sai
parlare di tutte è diventato tecnico
aiuto mi sapete dare dei conservate che
sembra un nano e di meno come se queste
fosse sono riuscito a rompere un
estintore franklin
io volevo parlare di chitarre in tutto
questo manco si può avere una
discussione c'è un casi oggi proprio non
puoi parlare della gente non può e credo
che questa sia un po difficile da fare
vista la stazza di questo qua allora
c'era la cassa delle nazioni no
rovesciato il whisky me la fai una
donazione si qua dentro per favore
venite lo lascio qua poi fai quello che
vuoi
joshua ma sei proprio tu mi scusi mi
scusi perché sta fissando il muro mi
scusi il muro e la domanda la mia è una
domanda la mia è una domanda non ho
fatto niente quello chiaro staccando
tutto aiuto datemi qualcosa è mancato a
pugni a puglia pugni a pugni suoi pugni
nelle mani via brutto riposo pezzente io
so che tu lavori con giva afe con il
dottor cartofilo solo vedo si vedono la
tua faccia che ce l'hai con me si vede
infine mi chiuse ti danno fastidio le
chiuse il consiglio quelle cos'è la vj
un cancro
roba lì tutto contro di me sì ma
picchiate vi anche tra di voi ct e
fastidio sempre su di me come se come se
avessi iniziato io non ho capito ma cosa
vuoi tu questo era pietro quello e
pietro questo ragazzi uguale no tu non
sei pietro pietro ragazzi ora pietro sto
tifo incredibile mi sa che tra un po
muoio e anche ingranato come pietro a
questa è la bottiglia da regalo ragazzi
uguale o picchiato pietro in un gioco
bouar madonna scusa pietro non volevo e
l'ho trovato quarto barile se non altro
guarda e meno male che si era gettato
ragazzi questo livello lo vedo molto più
difficile degli altri anche perché c'è
un sacco di gente iniziamo con giorgio
la social è a posto
mai cosi michael è a posto ragazzi sta
diventando veramente difficile però
importante che io sia sempre spillato
fratello becca testo ombrello era un
secchio ma fa niente
sentite ragazzi è sempre è sempre più
difficile anno prima che picchiarvi con
altra gente può essere un casino è però
si può fare finché si può fare
mi scusi joseph ops ho scoperto che
posso usare joshua per picchiare la
gente cosa fai un nuovo metodo per
suonare piano spiega mi è una cyclette
fammi sapere che cosa vi guardate jones
ragazzi e ubriachi timo menta ricordare
l'ormai guardate lui io chiamerei
l'ambulanza ragazzi un problema questo
corali joshua voglia dare una mano cosa
sta ma cosa sto giocando
ma a cosa sto giocare ma spiegatemi
maglia che male mi son fatto cos'era la
testata del letto
salve basta
ragazzi questo era un capolavoro
capolavoro videoludico moderno io non so
nel 2019 come non ho fatto giocare
13 euro di gioco per picchiare la gente
nei bar quando posso andare a casa di
pietro e farlo dal vivo sono gli sia
piaciuto lasciato un bel mi piace come
il commento sottoscrivete mi spiace che
la campanella ovviamente ci riescono
io vado a farmi rimborsare di questi 13
euro series
era come sempre ciglia della ragazza
[Musica]
no